GO TO BUYLEESA.COM TODAY. YOU
NEED THIS BED.
>> Tucker: WASHINGTON, D.C.
EXPERIENCED A MILD SNOW FALL
LAST WEEK.
LUCKILY CITY COUNCILMAN
TRAYON WHITE WAS ON IT.
HE KNOWS WHY IT HAPPENED.
WATCH.
THIS IT JUST STARTED SNOWING
OUT OF NOWHERE THIS MORNING.
Y'ALL BE BETTER PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS CLIMATE
CONTROL, MAN.
IT'S CLIMATE MANIPULATION
AND D.C. KEEPS TALKING ABOUT
ZILLION CITY A MODEL BASED
OFF ROTHSCHILD CONTROLLING
THE CLIMATE.
CREATING NATURAL DISASTER TO
PAY FOR CITIES.
BE CAREFUL.
>> Tucker: YEP, THE
ROTHSCHILD CONTROL THE
CLIENT.
THEY ARE OF COURSE, A
WEALTHY JEWISH BANKING CLAN
INCLUDED IN A GREAT MANY
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
RARELY GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR
WEATHER.
THAT'S AMBITIOUS NEW TWIST.
MARK STEYN IS AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST AND PART TIME
METEOROLOGIST.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
I LIVE HERE SO YOU CAN LAUGH
ALL YOU WANT.
THAT'S ACTUALLY NIGH MY CITY
COUNCILMAN THE ROTHSCHILD
CONTROL THE WEATHER.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
>> I DID, ACTUALLY, TUCKER.
THEY HAVE BOUGHT THE WEATHER